welcome to the presentation on more
advanced ratio problems so let's get
started with some problems
so let's say that i have a class
and then let's see
let me see oh the pen is messed up let
me see
okay so the class had in the class the
total number of students
is
and i would also tell you that the ratio
of
girls
to boys
is equal to
to 15.
so now this is the interesting part so
far doesn't look too tough my question
is
how many boys need to leave the room
so how many boys
how many boys
need to leave
for
ratio
of
girls to boys
to be
to 11. ah this is fascinating
so a good place to start is just to
figure out how many girls and how many
boys there are in this classroom and we
already learned how to do that in the
introduction to ratio problems
we know that the girls
plus the boys
equal to 57 right because there are 57
total kids in the room
and we also know just multiplying taking
this equation
and multiplying both sides by b we also
know that the girls
are equal to
4 over 15
times the boys right
and then we can just substitute that
back into this equation and then we get
over 15
b
plus b is equal to 57
and it's the same thing as
over 15 b
is equal to 57.
let me clean this up a little bit
that's separate and then let me go here
and then we say b
is equal to
57 a whoops it's actually 57 times
all of that over 19. right i just
multiplied both sides by 15 over 19. so
57 divided by 19
is
3. so b is equal to 45
and we know that there are total of 57
kids in the class
g plus b is 57
so we know that there are 12 girls right
57 minus 45 good
so now we know that the current the
current boys and girls are 40 40 45 boys
and 12 girls
so let's write that down so there's 12
girls
and
45 boys
now the question says how many boys need
to leave for the ratio of girls to boys
equals 4 to 11. so this is the number of
girls right now 12 this number of boys
let's say x is the number of boys that
need to leave the room
so
if x boys leave the room the new ratio
will be 12 girls to
the 45 boys minus the x boys that leave
right now
if that confuses you sit and sit and
look at that for a second we start off
with 12 girls and 45 boys in the room
and we're saying that x boys are going
to leave so the new ratio is going to be
12 to 45 minus x
and we know from this part of the
problem
that that new ratio is going to equal 4
to 11.
there we just set up a equation with one
unknown and we can solve for x i hope
that doesn't confuse you much all we did
is we figured out how many boys how many
girls are in the room now we said x is
the number of boys that need to leave
and then we said the new ratio is going
to be girls to the new number of boys
which is 45 minus x and that's going to
be equal to the new ratio
so let's solve for x
well 12 times 11 is what that's a 132
132 is equal to
4 times 45 160 180
minus 4x
and then if you solve for x i think you
know how to do this right now and we
could say let's see we could say
minus 4
x
is equal to minus 48.
x is equal to 12. there we solved it so
we say that if
12 boys left the room the new ratio of
girls to boys would be 4 to 11. and does
that make sense well 12 boys left the
room then the ratio of girls to boys
would be 12
to
right because 45 minus 12 is 33
and if that's the same thing as if we
divide the top and the bottom by 3 as 4
to 11.
so there we got it right so it looked
like a very hard problem actually wasn't
so bad when you uh
just you know sit down and and work
through the algebra
let's do another problem
let's say
let me
this thing sometimes malfunctions
okay let's say that the ratio
of
apples
to bananas in a basket is equal to 5
to 19.
and when we add 23 bananas
when we add
23 bananas
bananas
the ratio
of apples
to
bananas
and actually let's just write it right
now we now have 23 bananas more
is equal to
10 to 61.
so the question is
what is the total amount of fruit in the
basket
amount of fruit
that's so messy
after
adding the bananas
adding bananas
so i actually give you a hint just when
i wrote down the initial problem we're
saying that the ratio let's let's of a
to b so let's a equal the number of
apples and b is equal to the number of
bananas so the ratio of apples to
bananas equals 5 to 19.
when i add 23 bananas
so now the new ratio is going to be the
number of apples
to b plus 23 the new ratio is 10 to 61.
so how do we solve this well once again
we have two equations and two unknowns
we know that i guess let's take this
equation first because it's a little
more complicated
we know if we cross multiply
that
a
is equal to
b
plus
and if we divide both sides by 61 we
know that a is equal to
over
b
plus
230. over 61
right
and we could take this equation
and multiply both sides by b and we say
that a is equal to 5 19 b
right
well both of these are equal to a so so
we could set them equal to each other
and we get 5
over 19
b
is equal to
over
b
plus 230
times 61
and we solve for b well this might seem
complicated to you at first but it's
just a basic linear equation and for the
sake of time because i only have two
minutes left in this u-tube i'm just
going to solve for b and you get b
is equal to 38.
if b is equal to 38 we know that the
initial ratio is 5 to 19
so that's pretty easy we just say a is
equal to 5 over 19
times 38
is equal to 10. so the initial number of
apples was 10
the initial number of bananas is 38
right
so initially we started off with 48
pieces of fruit
and then we're going to add 23 more
pieces of fruit right
and 43 plus 28 that's what 71 pieces of
fruit
so let me review real quick what we said
we said that the the ratio of apples to
bananas is 5 to 19 and that's a is the
number of apples b is the number of
bananas
when i add 23 bananas i now have b plus
23 bananas the new ratio of apples to
total number of bananas is 10 to 61.
and i just used both of these equations
two equations and two unknowns
solved for a
and then substituted and then i solved
for b nothing fancy here i know there's
a lot of fractions here but if you just
work through this that fractions
actually work out and i was able to
solve for a and b add the 23 pieces and
i got 71 total pieces of fruit i think
you're now ready to try some of the more
difficult ratio problems have fun